[Music]
[Applause]
let me make way for your coach Calipari
Kentucky head basketball coach kind
enough to join us he was at the Knicks
game the other night how does that work
when you want to go to the Knicks game
who places the call and who tells you
where you get to sit
come on you know I'm calling William
Wesley I'm calling Leon Rhodes okay come
on you do it you do it okay if if I want
good seats I have to call
do you get to say hey I want to sit next
to
Aaron Rodgers or Jessica Alba
no no I don't uh they get to ask you if
they can sit next to me
maybe years ago that would be the case I
don't know about this year coach
far away from him as possible that's
right yeah you may be right you may be
right uh
how close do you think you were to you
know leaving Kentucky or them wanting
you to leave Kentucky like did it ever
get to the point where you had to have a
meeting to say you know where are we
going together
no no
you know here's my thing again
what we got going we we've been so at a
high level last year and the year before
we went 47 48 games in two years and two
NCAA tournaments and all that in a
normal place
that's wow we got this wrong in Kentucky
there's something different about
Kentucky good
and Kentucky good you know we've been
there I mean it was only when we the
season ended with Maxie
quickly Ashton Nick the guys we had on
that group where we could have won a
national title that year the we won the
league by three that was only a few
years ago yeah then you have the covert
year then the last two years but you
know what we've got a good group coming
in
the landscape has changed this transfer
stuff has changed stuff uh the name
image and likeness has changed stuff but
no I think we're on a good path
um you know I want to do some special
things here you know we got six years
left to do some really good stuff and I
think we're doing some staff things um
well what do you mean six years
well I I've got six years on a contract
and I'm like saying all right let's
let's make this run and let's do some
things let's get this back where we were
um and again you know we haven't been
that far I mean two years ago we were
the fifth overall seed
like you know I mean we and and a couple
of us lost to Saint Pete's I was just
somewhere last night and uh well when I
was at the Knicks game somebody came up
and said I'm a Saint Peter's graduate
thank you you made I said yeah well
you're really happy I wasn't really
happy and neither were the other schools
that lost to them after we lost to them
I mean they how about they could have
been in the final four yeah
so but anyway that's behind look you
know me I don't have a rear view mirror
my stuff is always looking ahead uh
what's next how are we first at it I
mean you're talking about name image and
likeness I don't like to get into that
with players because you don't come to
Kentucky I call that tripping over
nickels to try to get to an NBA Max
contract I mean we've probably got 12 or
13 guys in a league now that have max
deals and you got others it may be 15 16
in another year or two so
but our kids make more than anybody uh
you saw Jacob toppen on an ATT
commercial
um little Wayne's in my office saying
where's Jacob top and I saw him on that
a t commercial I'm you you've got John
Morgan Morgan and Morgan national stuff
because we're at Kentucky and because
you know our TV
even last year rated higher than anybody
what we do and what we're seeing but
these kids want what the other kids are
getting at other schools coach and and
they will but I'm not I don't want to go
in and the first thing I talk about is
name image and likeness that's not why
you come to Kentucky
that isn't yet you are gonna do better
than anywhere else you go but why talk
about that I mean literally
you're you're coming here
I've had many players say their first
year in the NBA was at Kentucky all that
we did how we practice how we competed
and that's what's happened you know case
and you know looking right now like a
lottery pick from last year's I mean
that's what this is about winning at the
highest level knowing that every game is
someone Super Bowl knowing you can hide
you're going to be on national
television and and Dan why do you think
people want to watch Kentucky so much
because they want to see us win no
no there was and when we're up 20 they
turn the TV off I understand that our
team does but all that you do by coming
here the competitive practices You Can't
Hide and now you're prepared for what's
ahead watching Julius watching bam
watching Emmanuel quickly
um you know seeing what Maxie did of
trying to go out west so I can see the
lakes and see those guys and Anthony and
Jared and wenyon and then seeing both
Jamal and and Devin trying to go out
west of what I miss Sacramento I mean
I'm so mad because I thought they could
advance and I'd have time but D Fox and
Malik and and Trey Lyles I mean these
kids are all competing somebody said how
they're getting older they're now 24 and
25 that's when they're coming into their
Prime
I'm wondering about you know transfer
portal name image and likeness and being
able to sustain that and want to
continue to coach we've seen some of
these coaches you know bayheim said you
know I've never been happier like it's
off my shoulders you know Coach K I know
getting older you know Jay Wright saying
man I've never felt better that I'm out
from this like
it's changed so much and I wonder if
it's just going to eat up these coaches
that it's not longevity wise where
you're going to stay 30 you know 30
years as a head coach in college
well at one school at this point that I
don't believe that'll ever happen again
but
for me I'm not in it
I'm trying to make sure whatever I'm
doing what makes me happy is seeing kids
improve and get better
and coming together and winning at the
highest level competing for national
titles winning national titles but the
whole point of it is am I able to help
kids and if I'm not because of the
transfer portal or nil that may change
things but right now again we got a
great class coming in of young people
we've got some vets coming back
I'm good with this but could you let's
see coach could you see getting players
who aren't going to be one and done
well
every player that comes here thinks he's
wanted I know but not all one's done no
and I tell them don't come here thinking
you're staying for one year
talk about two and three years and after
one if you're able to go I'll be the
first one right now I'm dealing with
when the season is in season it's all
about team I'm not worried about
individuals at that point but when the
year ends
it's always about the individual player
what's best that now not only NBA it's
thrown in the transfer portal so like
with Oscar he was in my office yesterday
and I'm talking to NBA teams I talked to
one owner about Oscar because he's going
to do some more workouts
and my thing right now is to do
everything I can to help Oscar get in
that League because I believe they'll
stay Oscars I just want to let people
know who you're talking about Oscar
shibway who's going to be a lottery who
no one who no well it won't be a lottery
pick but no one knows okay
no one knew who he was
he comes to Kentucky all of a sudden
this kid explodes and I'm telling you
the greatest kid do I want to coach
Oscar another year yes what am I stupid
stupid yes
I want to coach him another year but if
I'm doing right by him I gotta give him
every opportunity to run this out and
see exactly where he is and so but I've
also had to have kids walk in and say
coach I think it's better that I leave I
was with CJ Frederick and walked him
through that situation and tried to help
him and told him I'm disappointed you're
leaving but I understand
and let me help you and you walk through
it that way I'm not mad I'm mad because
you're leaving her you should never this
thing right now let me my opinion
transfer portal
in the past before they could live
without penalty I would help a kid
try to play right away
I I would I didn't care about a kid
sitting out but
you should be able to transfer once
without penalty because maybe the coach
lied to you maybe you picked the wrong
place maybe you overestimated who you
were
so you can leave if you graduate from
the other school you can leave again
that's two
if for some reason the coach gets fired
or leaves or whatever you should have
that option
short of that
anything should be added if you get a a
waiver for injury it gives you another
year if you get a waiver for mental
health
you get you need to step back yeah
you're having this step back get
yourself right and then we'll add a year
at the end that way you're having kids
transfer three and four times
it's it's not sustainable and it's not
good for young people
to just say well I'm doing this and I'm
trying to get this and I'm gonna go I
mean what we've been able to do is work
through stuff and that's kind of being
taken away so when you add that all
together it's a little bit of a cluster
right now we need and it all falls down
it all falls on coaches it's not falling
on College presidents it's not falling
on ads it's falling on coaches I just
talked to a women's Coach
and he said one of his girls left and
got money to go to the other
to the other program it's so it's
happening in women's basketball well we
saw that with Louisville uh they just
lost their best player and then I was
talking to Jimbo Fisher I said what's
happening in football he says oh my gosh
so there's got to be some guidance where
this the guard rails and what we do but
I said this from the beginning all of
this is going to help Kentucky kids are
going to want to transfer to Kentucky
we're going to be able to put the best
stuff together I'm not sure
if it's the best thing for college
sports or college basketball and coaches
many mid-level coaches are going to get
fired because their best players are
leaving and then they have a struggle
year and another struggle and they're
gone I mean it's not great for the
profession I don't think it's great for
the kids uh I'll leave you with this
have you recruited LeBron's son
well he was out west and I can't mention
all that LeBron's a friend
um but his son did get scholarship
papers when he was born so I sent
scholarship papers the minute he was
they said himself but to the hospital
LeBron's a great friend and I'm not
allowed to talk about it he's uh he's a
recruitable athlete oh
did you you'll get me in trouble
hold on socks what kind of socks do you
have on today Adidas don't tell me you
had
do you have socks on today yeah Adidas
okay do you remember the flowery ones
you had the last time yeah I couldn't
yeah what yeah what about it
you remember before the game you'd go
into court and shoot yeah and I put on a
damn display when I did
no no the Dayton stuff didn't come no
you no no see the fire department came
over that day and they said oh my God we
got to put that guy's arm out it's on
fire I called okay
you know it's a true story when when you
were up at UMass and I was putting on an
aerial display and a shooting in a
shooting performance there with flowered
socks on yeah and that's what the great
ones do
patino offered me um nio just letting
you know
[Laughter]
nothing to say it's it's great it's
great it doesn't happen very often but I
do not like that not done not really uh
hey good luck uh next year and uh thanks
I appreciate your time as always that's
uh that's coach John Calipari he gets
tickets to the Knicks games
got him all fired up there not allowed
to talk about LeBron's son get him in
trouble